base your relationships off your parents  relationship and if you watch your mum  or your dad constantly belittle  themselves and constantly let themselves  get walked over you're going to let  yourself get walked over because  when if you're on their gender because  it's more likely to be the woman you're  going to think oh it's okay it's more  likely to be the woman because like  domestic violence you're more likely to  be domestically abused most um domestic  violence is two-sided like a lot of  girls claim domestic violence but they  hit first okay um and you're actually  more likely to be in a domestic violence  um where if it's one-sided abuse like  women are more likely to be in uh more  likely to hit men once I did than men  are to hit women